i'm driving with rachel we're going to
uh
we're going to like freaking malibu
right right in the car
right and
one of these dumb big stupid dumb
motorcycles pulls up beside us
with speakers and the freaking music is
blaring
like
who are you
i don't even like when a car
i don't even like when a car is playing
loud music because i'm like yo
put your windows down nobody want to
hear your dumb ass music but when you
want a bike first of all the bike is so
big
get a car
okay just get a car the bike bike is big
as a freaking prius what are you doing
and then you got speakers on it blasting
out with a helmet on wear some damn
headphones i don't even
i do not understand that people that
ride motorcycles and play loud music
amplify music
eat it suck it
[Music]